dicht an dicht stehen die massen auf dem
bahnsteig in frankfurt unfassbare
aufnahmen die den u bahn wahnsinn in
deutschen städten zeigen denn in
stoßzeiten sieht es so oder ähnlich an
den bahnhöfen und u bahn stationen aus
das sagen pendler fahren sie mal mit der
bahn während schulschluss ist dann sieht
es so aus aber auch in der bahn und da
ist nicht möglich
anderthalb meter abstand zu halten also
da glaube ich auch nicht dass die maske
alleine was nützt wenn das alles dicht
auf dicht ist also sieht sehr nach vor
kurzer zeit aus aber das ist natürlich
schon heftig
yaez berufsverkehr wäre schön wenn man
das ein bisschen entfernen könnte also
ich würde da jetzt privat wenn ich nicht
nicht zur arbeit müsste da nicht nicht
aufhalten wollen
doch was ist die lösung vielleicht mehr
bahnen alle zehn minuten oder sowas oder
busse zwischendurch einsetzen jedenfalls
mehr verkehrsmittel damit die leute sich
besser verteilen können
das ist eine gute frage ich dann gäbe es
wahrscheinlich die stadt mit den
verkehrsbetrieben zusammensetzen und
gemeinsam an der lösung arbeiten
das wahrscheinlich auch schwierig weil
man genau diesen stoßzeiten dann so
massen hat zu bestimmten zeiten und
jetzt mittags es eher ruhig ist aber ich
glaube da kann man schon eine lösung
finden
die zeit menz herren also im prinzip ist
arbeitgeber in der pflicht genommen dass
er halt versucht die arbeitszeiten zu
ändern das was ich bin früh spät
mittelschicht keine ahnung nachtschicht
dass man das einfach ein bisschen
entzerrt das gesundheitsamt rät in
öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln korrekt und
konsequent maske zu tragen
zudem sind alle bürgerinnen und bürger
aufgerufen nicht zwingend notwendige
wege wo immer möglich zu vermeiden nach
einschätzung unter anderem des robert
koch instituts ist die gefahr der
ansteckung im öffentlichen nahverkehr
eher gering
bei diesen aufnahmen jedoch schwer zu
glauben während sich in fast allen
bereichen des alltäglichen lebens
einschränkungen bemerkbar machen scheint
hier einfach alles weiter zu laufen wie
vor corona mehr nachrichten und breaking
news nur weil welt schaut euch hier das
nächste video an und vergiss nicht zu
abonnieren